hey y'all jason here and i've got a big
announcement jubilee media is hiring
that's right if you're a director an
editor and post
we've got all these different roles and
we're looking for you my favorite part
about jubilee is working with just
incredible people who believe in the
mission of creating
a movement of empathy and we think that
could be you
so if you're interested make sure you
visit jubilee media.com careers
we look forward to hearing from you soon
now enjoy the episode
our ideal date is that we start with a
bar crawl and then we're going to go to
the beach
okay yeah that's yeah i mean we're both
sober but
[Music]
uh all right you want me to go first
this is salem he has like a 96 like
mustang convertible
and it's just fun to just go kick it and
cruise around so he uses me for my car
yeah i have a prius though salem is the
type of person to have three different
cameras
in his tote bag at once
[Laughter]
so this is riley uh he used to be a pro
finger deck decker and
uh yeah he was sponsored and everything
as far as music goes like
jamming with him is always a good time
things like that if you both
like the same person what do you think
you would do
we've actually dated the same person
like
we found out when they stopped talking
to each other i
was actually seeing them we're both
still friends with her and everything
and like i don't even think she's
i haven't talked to her
[Music]
what's happening yeah
is my face really red no okay and my
hands
hi um our ideal first date would be a
picnic at by a lake and i don't know
we'll eat like a truck booty board or
something
and like be bracelets and maybe like
paint something
yeah yeah i like that yeah it's like a
good time
okay so we were thinking that we would
go horseback riding on the beach
i was thinking about it and i could
definitely see you guys on some really
pretty horses yeah i have a horse so
i got a couple of hats okay it's really
exactly yeah it's really not it's real
it's happening we're getting sushi
orange juice and we're gonna have a
great time go to an abandoned building
and risk uh getting the recipe
trespassing oh word
yeah we start with a bar crawl and then
we're gonna go to the beach
okay all right yeah that's yeah i mean
we're both sober but yeah we'll go with
you
so we're both really big foodies so our
first ideal
double date would be like finding a new
restaurant to eat at parmesan fries
ooh yes hot little sugar yeah which is
good food the good stuff sugar
if we're going to be bonnie and clyde i
need to know were you the driver or the
shooter
okay for sure yeah whatever you need i
mean yeah he's the driver for sure yeah
pretty lookout like cliffs maybe we love
um landing grass yeah then we'll watch
an anime movie afterwards
demonstrator just coming out hit up a
museum and stare at pieces until we feel
something
um and then for night time we would go
stargazing and you guys know the game
like we're not really strangers
no okay it's like a card game that's
meant to like cause deep conversations
it's just a good question yeah
okay no don't wait
just take over and talk about it this is
horrible
i'm sorry sarah and destiny i'm sorry i
just didn't like demon slayer that's why
well they don't like demon slayers so
that kind of hurts i don't think i don't
think it would work out
i have to agree with her you guys back
there i'm sorry
i'm sorry it's fine i think if somebody
said orange juice
i don't know where she went with that
rosie and golden i'm so sorry
i think they're cool and maybe something
could have came out of it
but it's okay uh sorry jessica and
rachel
have a good time they're not as big as a
foodie as we are
but i guess we're just gonna go out and
get some food afterwards with each other
you know best eatable
date one more one more wait it's one
more frozen gamma
sorry y'all we can show our kids cause
it's gonna be on the internet forever
look at your moms get rejected but it's
cool
that was terrible that's
so exciting like i'm like shaking so
much
you're like this whole time i've been
like
hey guys so this is kylie she's really
loud but it's a good thing because
she'll protect me tati's the opposite of
me kind of in a way so we balance each
other out she's more quiet reserved she
gets along with everyone
this is miranda i've never met somebody
who's such a badass
has such a good and pure heart and she
inspires me to be more confident this is
kiana she is
literally the best die-hard ride-hard
friend you could ever ask for
not to mention she is the life of the
party anywhere we go
if keon is there it's gonna be a good
time thank you
cute this is shania one of the cutest
people
ever looking at her face i i can't um
also extremely affectionate she'll
always be hugging you and telling you
she loves you
this is michelle she will match you on
any energy if you want to be like scream
singing she will be there with you
if you want to like cry and just have
like a really deep conversation she'll
be there with you as well
she's also extremely intelligent like
literally like you would show her off to
your parents i am literally obsessed
with her
i spent 24 7 with her and i'm not sick
with her yet sick of her yet so yeah
this is bria i'm obsessed with her she's
super supportive spiritual
woke like she's spontaneous she got it
together
okay so this is tease my best friend my
soul mate if you ever want to have like
the
deepest conversation talk to her i've
never met anyone who is this beautiful
like look at her
she's gorgeous this is really my soul
mate i've never met anyone like her
she's amazing is this really
heartwarming i know
it's like it's so sweet do you feel that
way about me
no
[Laughter]
riley which girl do you think would be
best for salem
uh probably miranda for
salem probably uh i don't know i just
get a feeling
which contestant do you think would make
the most sense
michelle yeah
[Music]
you first uh taya and bria
they're super cool like we would be
friends with them for sure
especially salem salem you're awesome i
know we like the same one salem reminds
me of
the twins from the band the garden yeah
i don't know for sure
yeah for sure uh
yeah tatty and kylie
do you think anything would have been
your type no i don't know
that's i'm sorry
how are you guys feeling so far like
jerks yeah this is bad yeah
i feel rotten inside sorry guys yeah
sorry no hard drive
we're just looking to find out
[Music]
hi hey
okay cool how's it going pretty good i
don't really know what we're supposed to
talk about
hey guys good are you guys
good good good yeah this has been a
weird saturday but hey it's the name of
the game i guess
yeah yeah yeah you guys have all been
cool and stuff like that yeah oh yeah i
know you guys are cool too yeah
no also your guys's hair is like super
cool
we were talking about it backstage and
said he's got like the alice cooper
thing and i got like
all in the 70s yeah we're finishing up
at usc
so oh cool i studied business she's
chemical engineering
smarties what are you guys doing yeah
i'm an illustration major uh and i i
play music yeah and then i
do moderators do you guys have any like
pet peeves or like deal breakers
or anything i guess like mansplaining
it's like just it's basically no i don't
know okay yeah i'm just did it
wait a second we're in a band oh no way
we actually formed an impromptu band a
few weeks ago with some friends
oh hell yeah you guys play she's
basically a musical prodigy guys like
she's saying she plays piano she kills
it that's so sweet thank you
no we should do a jam session
yeah we play pretty much everything yeah
you can go no go ahead go ahead no it's
okay it's hard i would go for hair but
you guys both have awesome
hair okay
i'd probably go for you yeah there we go
i like really short hair amazing choice
thanks guys appreciate it
sounds good all right thank you guys
nice meeting you both yeah thanks for
talking all right nice meeting you guys
what's so awesome i think we like what
and then we were just like
super frazzled so yeah i didn't even
like think about like oh my goodness
what are like things to talk about it
was like
talk and i was like yeah are people
always this awkward on the speed dating
type stuff
or is it just us yeah are we on it
okay so the first pair that you talk to
is pair one second period you just have
to
go to on the count of three
i want you both to say either one or two
three two one two
[Laughter]
which one is it you guys you guys are
the final couple yeah
you guys welcome so cool that's so sweet
let's jam yeah let's jam i'm down do you
guys like want to exchange phone numbers
or something
okay definitely my phone's literally not
on me i can go gray i'll go grab my
phone
this is so exciting we should definitely
make a group chat and get it going
yeah can you play the drums i can yeah
we're trying to learn
oh yeah yeah if you can count to four
you can kind of do it
okay my mom called me like four times
his phone's dead
so classy okay no worries can we hide
yeah
[Applause]
we're gonna start a group chat we're
gonna get this going all four of us
hanging out like
we'd have a fun time yeah you know
jamming something you can do for like
six hours and like
not get bored so that's cool yeah